salut aujourd'hui je suis de retour pour
quelques vidéos dans ce bureau là
partout je vais je vous emmène avec moi
hier soir peu avant minuit on a passé
ensemble c'était un travail d'équipé
les deux cent mille personnes qui
suivent la chaîne juste un truc de ouf
je vous en reparle à la fin de la vidéo
il ya un peu plus de six mois de cela je
vous avais parlé de cette technique de
manipulation pour pouvoir les détecte et
surtout les contrées savoir comment
réagir en fonction de ça et bien
aujourd'hui je vous fais la suite de
cette vidéo ggg générer 10 précision
quand même par rapport à la manipulation
elle n'est pas toujours fait
consciemment de la personne qui est en
face de vous c'est aussi un moyen
parfois d'argumenter d'essayer d'obtenir
ce qu'on veut mais c'est pas forcément
très machiavélique c'est pas tout à fait
réfléchie
donc si vous en détecter une n'hésitez
pas à faire ce qu'on appelle un pont
d'or c'est à dire vous l'a cassée mais
vous ne culpabilisez pas la personne en
face vous essayez juste de remettre la
conversation dans un bon rail sur
quelque chose de plus concret vous
laisser une deuxième chance à la
personne la première technique dont je
vous parlais c'est ce qu'on appelle la
perspective piégé imaginant qu'il ya un
choix à faire
avant de faire ce choix on pourrait
établir une hélice avec des avantages et
des inconvénients mais si moi je veux
que vous ne fassiez pas ce choix là que
vous refusiez alors je vais vous
présenter un petit avantage et beaucoup
d'inconvénients
en clair je vais déformer la balance
elle va pas être objectif donc quand
vous présentent des avantages et des
inconvénients penser à l'objectivité
n'hésitez pas à demander à la personne
d'étoffé celle qu'elle a négligé et d'un
point de vue plus général garder
l'esprit critique pour voir si la
personne n'est pas en train d'essayer
simplement d'argumenter sa thèse à elle
c'est souvent une thèse non dit deuxième
technique de manipulation bien connu de
nos amis les médias la fosse corrélation
entre a&p faire un rapport entre deux
choses qui n'ont rien à voir ensemble et
tout le vendre comme si c'était lié
si j'avais eu assez de temps pour seul
j'aurais fait une courbe de progression
du nombre d'abonnés sur la chaîne du
cantal bloquent cette année et en
parallèle et en rapport vous aurez fait
une courbe de progression du nombre
rendue peu de mayonnaise de cette année
en cherchant bien on peut trouver un
rapport alors que vous et moi on sait
qu'il ya pas de rapport entre les
parfois c'est moins flagrant les
manipulateurs dans ce cas met en rapport
deux choses qui n'ont pas de sens qui
n'ont pas de lien direct ou qui omet un
troisième facteur c ou un quatrième
facteur d qui explique en fait pourquoi
toutes ces relations là existe trois y
ait des techniques de manipulation le
piège de la cohérence
alors ça c'est rarement fait par hasard
quand même de la part du manipulateur
qui va commencer à vous poser des
questions qui n'ont pas un rapport tout
à fait direct ça paraît floue en fait
par rapport à ce que vous êtes en train
de parler ou l'argumentaire surtout
qu'en général les questions vous savez
qui connaît déjà perd finalement la
réponse mais vous répondez quand même
en fait il est en train de vous amener à
une cohérence pour vous amener une
démonstration que vous penser ceci ou
que vous pensez cela alors que c'est pas
la carte ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
sent vraiment arriver on sent qu'il ya
quelque chose qui ne va pas on sent
qu'on nous force à donner des réponses
pour les exploiter plus tard et en
général le manipulateur et plus à
l'écouté et romance avec beaucoup de
questions quand vous sentez ce arrivé
n'hésitez pas à donner votre réponse en
complétant vous donner cette réponse là
parce que c'est ce que vous pensez
évidemment sur ce chemin de manipulation
c'est quand même ce que vous vous pensez
vous à ce moment là et vous complétez en
dix ans mais je vois où tu veux en venir
je sais ce que tu veux me faire dire ça
n'a pas de lien avec ce qu'on est en
train de discuter mais donner la clé à
la personne en face que vous avez
compris là où d'essayer de vous emmener
et que c'est pas la peine de perdre du
temps avec ça un peu en rapport avec le
2 et le 3 il ya la technique du faux
choix c'est à dire que on va simuler un
choix enfin le manipulateur va simuler
de vous proposer un choix mais parmi ce
choix ya qu une seule proposition
d'acceptable les autres sont
parfaitement inacceptables
mais ça veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre choix d'autres alternatives mais
présenté comme ça on a l'impression
qu'on a le choix qu'entre à b et c
le manipulateur veut nous forcer à
prendre c est pour ça il va faire en
sorte de créer un arrêt 1b complètement
fallacieux inacceptable par exemple pour
les vacances tu préfères bague on reste
à la maison à ne rien faire ou alors
qu'on aille à la mer ou conjugale air a
essayé d'aller dans les montagnes pour
faire les randonnées
et sur les refuges où on sait même pas
si on a de la place pour dormir qu'est
ce tu préfères en forçant comme ça la
personne à répondre parmi ce choix on
essaie d'occulter qu'il ya plein
d'autres possibilités que celles que la
personne nous aimer 5e techniques de
manipulation qu'on voit pas mal en ce
moment avec les politiciens et c'est
pour ça que ça me fait penser pour vous
en parler c'est la technique de
lentilles calomnie la personne va dire
quelque chose ou on veut pas être inclus
en fait dans le début de sa phrase on
veut pas subir la calomnie qui est en
train de prononcer et du coup on va le
suivre
c'est le genre de phrase qui commence
par si on est vraiment quelqu'un
d'honnête
alors on ne peut que bla bla bla bla bla
peu dans le même style il ya vraiment
que les gens un peu stupide ou en qui on
peut pas faire confiance qui dirait que
ceux-ci ceci cela vous voyez un petit
peu le chemin qu'on emprunte là on veut
pas surtout pas être inclus dans ce sac
de mauvaises personnes rires ça c'est la
technique de manipulation qu'on appelle
gentil calomnie quand vous détectez une
manipulation en face il ya des solutions
et les deux solutions les plus
intéressantes c'est d'ignorer et
poursuivre vous faites semblant ne pas
avoir été atteint de venir vous n'avez
pas été atteint et vous poursuivez comme
si de rien était vous ne répondez même
pas à cette technique de manipulation
faire un petit peu l'idiot en répétant
votre dernier argument la dernière chose
que vous avez dit eh bien vous le
répéter ou vous leur formuler comme si
la personne n'avait pas compris du coup
il y avait un petit quiproquo
c'est une manière élégante de casser la
manipulation et de remettre le débat au
bon endroit où la conversation au bon
endroit centre était l'hôte de
manipulateur puisque encore une fois je
vous rappelle qu'il souvent il ya des
manipulations qui sont complètement
inconsciente d'ailleurs faut pas voir
les manipulations partout après il fait
d'essayer de convaincre les choses la
manipulation c'est un grand mot comme ça
qui fait peur voilà pour ce nouvel opus
sur la manipulation je reviens sur le
côté on est 200 milles maintenant plus
de 200 milles sur cette chaîne sur le
mental blog que j'ai lancé le 1er
janvier 2016 donc 333 jours après moins
de 11 mois après on a passé les deux
cent mille personnes qui suivent ça
c'est ouf je tenais sincèrement à vous
remercier j'ai une petite surprise pour
vous on s'était fait un trip d'ailleurs
pour pour le passage des 200 milles avec
max va pas se mentir on a gagné c'était
la vidéo de samedi il y en a qui ont
adoré le délire y en a qui ont détesté
ça nous en tout cas avec max on s'est
bien marré elle faire et c'était un
chouette clin d'oeil auprès de nos
abonnés
vidéo un peu différente sur les 333
alors pour vous remercier parce que
encore une fois pour l'instant je m'en
remets pas dire qu'il faut savoir que le
2 octobre on faisait le meet up pour les
cent mille abonnés le 12 octobre dernier
c'est pas si loin que ça et ça me donne
une patate pour continuer je vous
raconte même pas mais je m'égare pour
vous remercier de ça je suis en train de
créer un petit jeu un petit quelque
chose qui va vous permettre de
mentaliser les gens autour de vous il va
me falloir encore quelques jours pour
finir de le créer de l'imprimé etc
mais c'est quelque chose que je peux
vous offrir à vous vos abonnés de la
chaîne qui me suivait soit depuis le
départ soit qui m'ont découvert il ya
pas longtemps mais peu importe le but
c'est que ce soit un vrai cadeau donc
que ce soit gratuit et que et que vous
ayez ça parce que vous êtes abonné et
que du coup vous regardez cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout mais forcément comme je
veux que ça reste gratuit ça va me
coûter une blinde si je vous les envoie
tous surtout si vous êtes 200 villes à
le vouloir se ferait beaucoup ça ferait
beaucoup mais je le ferai mais pourtant
je voulais que ce soit un vrai cadeau
physique
alors j'ai trouvé la solution je vais
mettre un google forme dans la
description de cette vidéo sur ce google
forme vous vous inscrivez et d'ici
quelques jours juste avant que je sois
prêt je vous enverrai un mail avec une
adresse à cette adresse là vous enverrai
une enveloppe timbrée avec votre adresse
offre nombre et avec un timbre normal un
amoureux rouge si possible une enveloppe
format a5 ster les enveloppes comme
salle de cette taille là vous mettez
donc un petit timbre ici vous mettrez
votre adresse vous en verrez ça à
l'adresse que je vous enverrai par mail
et si j'ai deux cent mille enveloppe
envoyée
je le ferai je prendrai des gens pour
m'aider mais je le ferai j'espère bien
sûr que cette idée pour célébrer ce cap
ça vous fera plaisir autant que le
plaisir que j'ai eu en regardant le
compteur bougé hier soir merci beaucoup
d'être là si vous n'étiez pas abonnés
avant cette vidéo merci d'avoir rejoint
la chaîne et vous pouvez cliquez juste
ici et vous pouvez aussi participer il y
aura aussi un cadeau pour vous et le
mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
depuis le 1er janvier depuis 333 vidéo
mais ces vidéos elle n'existe que parce
que vous êtes là pour les regarder
merci beaucoup rendez vous demain à 17
heures chalon